I'd say 23andme is so as much as we have
the reputation for being the consumer
oriented company and we are consumer
oriented were so heavy on the science
that to us it was it was sort of obvious
you know of course you're going to want
your genetic information we all want our
genetic information why would you not
want you netic information and I think
that that's probably something that we
we underestimated in terms of the fact
that people don't really necessarily
know exactly why you know what do they
want to do with them from what do they
want to do with the genetic information
why would they want it and and creating
you know I think about other industries
where it's been a big technology shift
so something like tivo tivo was a big
shift in how people watch TV but
everyone understood the concept of TV no
one really understands the concept of
why would I want my genetic information
and and I think one of the other big
challenges that we have is that people
health care is not a true and just
Healthcare's on a true free market
because you are used to going to your
doctor and saying you want x y and z and
not paying for it and and so for that
reason as telling people wow you can get
access to your genetic information it's
much cheaper than you know some of the
other ways you could get it and it's all
within your control that that's actually
a hardly for a lot of people because
they're not used to paying for anything
for healthcare so it's one of the things
that we fat we've discovered that we
have to educate people a lot more about
you know preventative care why they
should actually invest in that and what
are things that they should do with the
information and the fact that they
actually are going to have to take a lot
more responsibility for for their health
and and that's a that's a pretty big
adjustment for people
I think there's huge those huge
questions to to deal with it was funny
early on in the company we engaged with
a number of different bioethicists and
we actually talked about employing
someone and then we actually couldn't
get anyone to join because everyone
found that this topic was so interesting
that they felt that this was going to be
pivotal to their academic career so so
we've engaged with a number of people
we've gotten them to you know always
give us feedback on it but fundamentally
one things we've realized it's an
instant incredibly interesting area for
the ethics community to talk about you
know fundamentally what 23 Emmy believes
is that it's really about choice and if
you want to get access to something that
is fundamentally yours we believe it's
your right to get access to it it's not
for everyone that's abundantly clear to
us and those people should not have to
do it and so you know 23 Emmy really
wants to encourage the debate we want to
encourage the debate we want to be a
participant in it we want to be
supportive of it and I think we remain
very firm and that we believe
individuals should have the right to get
access to this information and how it's
going to be used and what are the right
what are the good things or what are the
bad things that society really needs to
have that debate and 23 Emmy will be
there but it's society to should put the
limits on it